hi everyone my name is Tamara chambers
and this is Tamara just saw and today I
got to see Ferdinand just kidding I saw
Star Wars first things first this is
going to be a spoiler filled reaction
video I am not talented enough as a
reviewer to step around all the crazy
and wonderful surprises that happened in
this film so if you haven't seen the
movie don't watch this I'm wearing a red
dress and I showed up to the theater
last night dressed as ray very excited I
got home like 2:30 a.m. and I didn't
fall asleep until like 5 because I was
just thinking about it so much there was
so much to process in this film and upon
thinking about it there were some lulls
in a storyline there were a couple
things that could have been cut I think
things that I cared more about that
could have gotten more time less about
they could have got last time but I
still absolutely loved it I loved force
awakens as well but this felt more og
Star Wars even though there were some
moments in it where things happened that
have never happened in Star Wars before
interesting things that characters have
never been able to do were able to do in
this film it still felt like a really
nice connection to the original 3 the
original trilogy I think that the
creatures in this were way more og Star
Wars
I thought the poor's I'm sorry if you
don't like porks but I love the porks I
thought puppet Yoda was just such a
great moment the story is really about
Ben solo and Rey finding what's inside
of themselves the dark side the light
side what level of each they have and
kind of processing through that it's
also about the resistance just trying to
survive basically Cody just text me a
picture of the Praetorian Guard which we
have grown to love
that's another character that I will be
bringing up oh say hi to Cody everyone
you get to see a lot more of Poe in this
and a really nice character change for
him being like this go get him dude
who's gonna do things but by his own
rulebook and kind of Han Solo II in that
sense and but whereas Han like was
always right about it Poe's very much
was not and he was able to turn his way
of thinking around which was really nice
to see you see Luke doing things that
that Jedi have not ever done before and
it's awesome this morning I was on
Twitter just looking through all the
Star Wars tweets and I saw a lot of
people did it like this film which
didn't even cross my mind that that
would even be a possibility because I
loved it so much I just was smiling from
ear to ear the whole time unless I was
crying from the sheer brilliance of some
of the action sequences it seems that
people aren't digging the newer elements
to it and I just think that's so crazy
to me feels you're gonna feel of course
but I don't know we want new Star Wars
content so there's got to be some
changes and some like additions to the
story I know there's a lot of like
extended universe stuff and things that
people are gonna be like well they could
have done that they didn't have to add
new things I don't know I I'm all about
adding things if they're done well I
thought it was done really well you got
a lot of Leia which was incredible there
was a lot of tender moments I don't know
if they had to like reshoot any lines
after she had passed Carrie Fisher but
it seems like they knew and were kind of
playing into some of it with some
sweeter moments the end Luke goes to her
and says no one's ever really gone
there's just some really tender moments
with Leia and it's what everyone wanted
and it was beautiful
so she doesn't die in this film which
shots the hell out of me like what are
they gonna do what are they gonna do oh
my god I mean I'm happy I'm so glad well
there's plenty of teasing that she is
going to die in the film and then she
doesn't the best way a moment did I also
think people might not like is
she gets blown out of a ship and she
uses the force I'm gonna cry just
thinking about now it was so amazing she
uses the force to pull herself back into
the ship and at first I was like flying
what is this it would have been a really
easy choice for them to have just like
killed her off because she had a really
beautiful moment where she was floating
there in outer space
and she looked peaceful and and I was
like oh my god this is the end this is
the end of Leia and it wasn't but she
just like force pulled herself right on
in the weirdest part though
character-wise for me was Finn and joy
and no rose I love rose
she's got a great moral compass very
hard worker I love Finn as well I didn't
love their storyline and I think that's
probably pretty universe it just felt
unneeded because in the end it literally
is unneeded nothing comes of it so they
go off and they they're trying to find
this hacker the hacker the coder that
they find it is awesome I really liked
his acting but again really just
unneeded do they go find this guy they
go into like this weird casino planet
they free some some beasts and it's fine
but it feels like like a spin-off movie
like it feels like why is this happening
right now I would have so much rather
seen what Rey was up to I loved her in
this on the casino planet you did see
the little boy who uses the force at the
very end that was cool I feel like they
were setting up something for nine where
there might be a new children's academy
who have you know elements of the force
a force sensitive Snoke sucks he's just
like a bad guy he looks pretty cool I
guess but he's just kind of like there
and it's just a way for you to see that
kylo Ren is kind of trying to decide
between joining Rey starting his own
thing or taking over and so he ends up
taking over there are three sequences
film that blew me the actual away and
one of them was when kylo Ren kills
Snoke and then him and Rey team up
together to kill the Praetorian guards
the wide shot of them fighting the
Praetorian guards is so incredible
back-to-back lightsabers drawn and then
the guards all around them it's just
beautiful there was moments of silence
in it and the way that you silence in
this film was amazing everyone was
cheering everyone was just hyped as hell
and it's such a good action
the guards are a really cool thing it
seems like there was a lot of samurai
influence with them the next sequence
that was just incredible is the last
standing person with amazing blue purple
hair in their main ship turns the ship
around and light speeds into the ship
and destroys it and it's this wide shot
in silence ah and then of course the
last incredible sequence is Luke
Skywalker fighting kylo Ren and it was
so good again white shots again use of
silence I love the difference between
their fighting styles Luke Skywalker has
such a Jedi Master fighting style and
kylo Ren is like this fit filled frenzy
so they're on this new planet called
Crete Crete creed visit Creed it had
this really cool element where the
ground is just covered in salt and when
you skirt your leg across it or foot
across it it becomes red and kylo Ren is
fighting so aggressively and all of his
foot motions are making red marks in the
salt and and I love that they made it a
point to show you that Luke's didn't so
of course it didn't cuz he wasn't
actually there but I just I was like oh
maybe he's just so light on his feet no
no he's just forced placing himself
there so cool it was sprinkled with
really delightful bits of comedy a lot
coming from Luke from Yoda some from
couple of the creatures you get a look
of blue milk other than the fin Rose
storyline the the only thing that I
really didn't like is the 25 minute
frozen short at the beginning of the
film
I loved this movie so much this is maybe
in the contender for top Star Wars film
for me I gotta give it another
rewatching or two or three obviously I'm
definitely still on that hype train I'm
seeing it and just feeling the energy
from the crowd I said this when I saw
force awakens but this really makes you
just want to go revisit the films and
that's why I think it is more of a Star
Wars feel it's like the most Star Wars
Star Wars they're ever Star Wars because
it just it makes me love the franchise
again I never didn't but it just it
really brings you back into that like
feel I hope you liked it too and I hope
that maybe after a reviewing if you
didn't it grows on you a bit more I
absolutely enjoyed this so much thank
you so much for watching may the force
be with you always
I'll see you next week
[Music]